In a world
Hi there! Welcome to the Wall.
Look at this as a chance for a brand new life.
Cherie! Cherie! Cherie!
What the fu-
Shhh!
where many are looking for a way out,
one hero
Thanks for coming, Halk.
You're the only one qualified enough to help.
is looking for a way in.
You saved so many.
But not everyone.
I got to help them with this investigation.
But the nightmares!
A way to discover the truth.
I'll make sure everyone here is safe.
A way to find redemption.
These kind of things don't happen in here anymore.
We have a theory,
big 'ole cricket.
A way into the mind
You think a cricket did this?
of a killer.
We have a serial killer on our hands.
But in the wall,
even small secrets
What you've done goes against
everything we fought for!
have big consequences.
And this killer's secret
The story you know,
It's a lie.
can send the whole world
tumbling down.